[Musique]
salut a tous ravis de vous retrouver ici
à bruxelles au parlement européen c'est
parti pour 30 minutes de décryptage de
l'actualité des 28
dans cette émission direction l'autriche
les autrichiens depuis quelques années
ont rétabli le service militaire pour
les seuls garçons une volonté porté par
la population alors à l'heure où
emmanuel macron souhaitant france
instauré un service universel
obligatoire reportages et débats
à suivre mais d'abord l'actualité un an
des élections européennes les familles
politiques commencent à s'organiser
emmanuel macron se verrait bien réitérer
l'exploit dans marche au niveau européen
avant d'en débattre avec mes invités
état des lieux avec aurélie la face
[Musique]
regardons les choses en face comment se
satisfaire des élections européennes
auxquelles moins d'un citoyen sur 2 se
déplacent pour voter alors construisons
dans l'année qui vient la réalité d'un
débat structuré sur des convictions des
propositions 17 avril le discours d'
emmanuel macron a des airs de lancement
de campagne le président français essaie
de tracer sa voie au centre en
transcendant les clivages politiques
classiques reproduire au niveau européen
la stratégie qui l'a porté au pouvoir en
france et faire entrer en force le
maquereau nice ou au sein du parlement
de l'union
partout en europe les partis historiques
sont fragilisés en italie et en
allemagne
les formations traditionnelles de
gouvernement ont reculé aux dernières
élections et les partis se sont englués
dans de longues négociations de
coalition
en france les républicains et le parti
socialiste peine à s'organiser face à
ces difficultés les partis europhobes
d'extrême droite se met en ordre de
bataille
le front national de marine le pen
affiche sa volonté de mener des actions
communes avec des partis étrangers comme
la ligue du nord de l'italien matteo
salvini à gauche des alliances
transnationales prennent forme également
benoît hamon désormais à la tête du
mouvement génération sera proche de
l'ancien ministre des finances grec
yannis varoufakis il appelle au
rassemblement des forces de gauche aux
européennes
jean luc mélenchon va quant à lui
chercher des alliances avec les
espagnols de podemos et le bloco
portugais trois formations de gauche
radicale
à un an des élections les forces
politiques se mettent en mouvement en
europe
[Musique]
alors à un an des européennes quelles
sont les équilibres politiques pour en
débattre sylvie guillaume bonjour vous
êtes députée européenne groupe donc des
socialistes et démocrates vous êtes vice
présidente de ce parlement bienvenue à
vous dominique riquet vous êtes vous
membre du groupe des démocrates et des
libéraux pour l'europe
vous êtes français enfin frank engel
vous vous faites partie du groupe du
parti populaire européen donc et vous
êtes luxembourgeois alors peut-être un
mot sur la stratégie d' emmanuel macron
il était donc au parlement européen le
17 avril dernier
dominique riquet ce que vous pensez
véritablement que le maquereau nisme en
europe peut-être en marche
il a d'intérêt à définir un programme
c'est clair et peut-être à élargir la
consultation donc ça très bien
en revanche le paysage politique des
différents états des différents pays est
assez différent du paysage politique en
france 9e je pense que la stratégie du
président a été excellente la preuve en
france mais qu'elles s'appliquaient un
paysage qui a été bien qualifié
d'ailleurs deux extraordinaires
surprenant imprévisible en réalité dans
beaucoup de pays comme celle montée des
extrêmes le paysage politique et restait
beaucoup plus stable est ce que vous
êtes d'accord
frank engel comment est ce que vous
voyez cette stratégie depuis le
luxembourg
premièrement je vois que je vois qu'il
ya manifestement à la tête de la
république française quelqu'un qui
aurait envie de marquer de son empreinte
plus de territoire que le seul français
qui vu du luxembourg est déjà plus grand
que le nôtre mais je réalise en même
temps que cela sera sans doute plus
difficile à l'échelle continentale que
cela
ne l'a été en france veut chez nous par
exemple ne verrez nulle part de l'espace
pour qu elle pour quelque chose qui
serait en marche
il y avait une volonté en fait de la
part d' en marge de créer une task force
justement pour aller créer des alliances
on a vu que les 5 étoiles lorgnait un
peu que ciudadanos en espagne sylvie
guillaume
est-ce qu'il ya pas aussi une volonté de
se raccrocher à une forme de dynamique
comme ça pr ropéenne dans dans certains
pays d'europe
c'est vrai qu'en france on a noté que la
voir un président qui soit ouvertement y
compris depuis la campagne électorale
présidentielle ouvertement européen
s'est plutôt bien et c'est évidemment un
facteur tout à fait favorable mais être
sur un prisme ou une grille de lecture
qui soit exclusivement il ya les pros ou
les antilles tout c'est un peu juste
mais il ya aussi une grille de lecture
qui est politique qui est libéral pas
libéral de gauche - de gauche bref il ya
des curseurs qui sont un peu différents
la deuxième chose à mon avis qu'il faut
avoir en tête c'est que en france
l'élection européenne s'est beaucoup
basé et c'était pas que du côté des
manuels macron sur le on dégage tout le
monde
le dégage élections nationales les
élections président oui présente
présidentielle nationale et je pense que
c'est ce registre là n'est pas
exactement adapté à l'enjeu européen est
enfin là où franck agah avez raison
c'est que on a aussi peut-être de notre
côté français c'est pas illogique une
loupe sur un fonctionnement qui est pas
forcément perçu de la même manière avec
la même intensité dans d'autres états
membres
moi je vois dans mon groupe un certain
nombre de mes collègues me disent mais
ça va avec ton macron alors bon c'est à
côté du j'assume pas forcément c'est ce
type de discours mais je le dis avec un
peu de caricatures parce que ça résume
un peu aussi l'état d'esprit alors on
voit aussi que il ya une forme de
replacements idéologique de la part de
plusieurs partis européens je pense
notamment au parti populaire européen
j'aimerais qu'on voit un tweet de du
président du groupe
ici au parlement demande secrète webber
qui twittait donc il y a quelques
semaines avant la victoire de viktor
orban en autriche qu'il était nécessaire
en fait de défendre notre manière de
vivre et qu'il le fallait déterminer en
fait d'eux les besoins européens et la
nécessité d'un débat sur l'identité
et la culture dominante et tout ça sur
fond de cathédrale alors frank henkel
vous faites partie de ce groupe
mais retourne vers 20 vous ne cédez à la
tête
qu'est ce que ça veut dire est-ce qu'on
est elle la face une forme
d'organisation du parti conservateur
européen et qui est pourtant le parti
majoritaire ici au parlement
je vais vous dire que cette organisation
a lieu depuis un certain temps déjà mais
elle connaît ses limites
on ne va pas mourir dans les émois ouais
j'aurais pris à quitter parce que des
sacs d'engrais dire écoutez pour moi
nous avons co fondé le pp mais nous ne
tolérerons pas que les ppa se transforme
en une prolongation du stupide isme
endroits tels que tel qu'on le voit à
l'oeuvre et nous ne succomberons pas non
plus à cette tentation qui semble
actuellement bavaroise de dire il faut
il ya des élections je vois tout ça et
on verra comment ça c'est tout cela
évolue a évolué après septembre quand
seront faites les élections bavaroise à
la fin du compte
l'europe ne se réduit pas à la croix et
j'ai trouvé excellent comment le chef de
la conférence épiscopale allemande
le cardinal marx a devancé le cerezo en
bois en bavière ont dix ans mais vous
n'avez aucun droit de politiser la croix
je souhaiterais qu'on arrête ces bêtises
et qui on est cons et qu'on regarde
notre continent en face avec toute la
diversité qui était toujours la sienne
et qui est aujourd'hui encore plus la
sienne
cela ne va pas changer nous adaptons à
ça soit nous ratons la cible et ce n'est
pas avec une crois qu'on va régler ça à
quoi qu'il en soit on a effectivement ce
sentiment en fait que les partis qui
sont plutôt à l'extrême de l'échiquier
politique ce sont eux très bien
organisés les alliances se nouent
il ya un travail en fait en bas on l'a
vu avec marine le pen on le voit avec
jean luc mélenchon et les alliances avec
mots des mots sous le bloc au diester ya
d'abord au portugal je serais tenté de
dire qu'est ce qui se passe au milieu
qu'est ce qui se passe justement chez
les pee qu'est ce qui se passe chez les
socialistes
qu'est ce qui se passe chez les en
marche chez les centristes on a un peu
ce sentiment que on attend vidéo non
nous on n'attend pas alors on a passé
une phase un peu compliqué comme vous
l'avez
manifestement compris on a passé notre
congrès maintenant on est dans une phase
de redémarrage
on a conscience de nos échecs je crois
mais conscience aussi de ce que
représente la marque parti socialiste
qui est pas une marque qui va comme ça
disparaît aussi vite et surtout on a
cette conscience de regarder ce qu'ils
aient repris ou pas des propositions que
nous avons depuis longtemps mis en place
au plan européen et sur lesquels assez
curieusement c'est intelligemment je ne
sais pas le parti de emmanuel macron
vient aussi mais on a nos critiques
frank engel est ce que vous êtes
d'accord je ne vais pas me laisser dans
la vie intérieure du parti socialiste
français que l'on met ensemble il me
semble pour l'instant effectivement
passé une très mauvaise phase j'oserais
espérer que cela ne soit une femme oui
mais après il ya effectivement toutes
nos social démocratie européenne qui
semblait c'est là mon problème moi je
crois qu'on ne peut pas faire de la
politique
n'importe comment et avec n'importe quoi
mais au fond en marche
c'est quoi veut ça veut quoi je ne vais
pas encore tout à fait saisi je n'en
prenais pas pris la ligne politique non
mais jardon mais je consomme je constate
me fait marrer droite ni de noël
certains se plaignent surtout que ce que
ce que ce soit surtout une caisse de
résonance pour un seul homme veut et je
n'ai pas l'impression qu'avec cela est
de cette façon ça s'inscrivait dans la
durée
oui dès lors si ça veut s'inscrire dans
la durée il faudra plus que l'attrait
qu'ils aient fait considérable je
concède instinct seul homme fût-il
président de la république dominique
riquet vous qui seriez plutôt ouvert à 7
à cette famille politique c'est quoi
dans cette fois c'est quoi le squelette
idéologie oui mais pour le coup vous
êtes chez les adl donc les libéraux
démocrates menés par guy verhofstadt et
il semblerait qu emmanuel macron n'est
pas pour l'instant particulièrement
envie en fait d'entrer dans cette
famille politique il ya plein de
tactique dans lequel jeu sur lequel je
défendrai pas aujourd'hui parce que je
crois que la proposition qui devrait se
faire jour dans des démocraties matures
pour laquelle moi comme centriste je
prêche depuis de nombreuses années
commencent à dire que la france n'est
pas une démocratie mature est passé à
une forme de démocratie parlementaire à
la demande
on a toujours été un peu énervé
c'est que il y a deux nécessité une
union entre les démocrates sociaux et
des sociaux-démocrates voilà le sujet et
puis après des partis protestataires
organisé le vol qui s'est fait avec les
radicaux notamment en france oui on
derniers rivaux ces voix là y'en a rien
demandé début décembre
c'est un effort pourquoi parce que un
art du compromis en france en europe et
en france pas très très bien
donc si je suis démocrate social je
discute pas et et sociaux démocrates
en fait je crois que les gens ne veulent
plus de ça les gens ils veulent quelque
chose qui soit équilibrée face au
problème de la mondialisation face aux
pointes des dangers sécuritaires qui
vole une position équilibrée
sauf que pardon discuter entre des
forces politiques dont la philosophie
est différente et on est bien placés ici
au parlement européen pour savoir que
c'est possible que c'est souhaitable que
quelquefois ça marche que ça permet de
faire des pas mais à mon avis on a un
problème de lisibilité du résultat et
discuter ne veut pas dire qu'on partage
d'une certaine manière c'est aussi lit
les habilités ou le côté statique de de
cette politique et de son application
qui n'est pas perçue par les citoyens
dont c'est ça aussi qui va être en jeu
dans la future que les élections
européennes
et là en tout cas dans la campagne ça
c'est exactement la politique d'avant
non visibilité schiste eagle scission
mais non pas du tout c'est à dire je
vous dis exactement le contraire on peut
discuter mais ça veut pas dire que nous
concluons des alliances surtout s'en fut
ne plus faire de politique
sous des angles réellement politique moi
je moi je mets moi je peux vous dire que
au luxembourg on a l'habitude presque
séculaire maintenant de coalition ça
fonctionne très bien
on n'a pas besoin de fusionner on voit
bien par exemple qu'en italie ou en
allemagne
on était en italie vous avez vu avant
l'impossibilité de kwal de coûts
réalisées actuellement le fondement d'un
ancien système pauline s'en moque aussi
chrétienne s'est effondré il ya 25 ans
déjà n'a jamais été remplacés sauf par
ce truc de silvio qui l'appelle comme ci
ou comme ça au bout de ces au bout de
ses rayons et on irait vers de nouvelles
élections de la preuve politique mais
c'est là où on voit quand même que si
quelque chose ne se structure pas dans
le contenu
mais juste autour de personnes ça n'ira
pas la lisibilité dogmatique à mon avis
c'est fini la lisibilité à doite
programmatique ça que les gens attendent
programmatique mais un programme qui va
au delà en fait de l'incarnation par un
seul homme ce que j'entends dans la boue
et les autres il ya autre chose il ya
autre chose contre lequel je ne veux pas
nous ériger un grand exemple de quelque
chose dans une somme après tout un grand
duché mais un petit territoire
mais nous n'avons nous ne commettons
quand même pas au luxembourg une erreur
que j'ai vu maintenant à l'oeuvre en
allemagne et rien d'autres parties de
l'europe et où ça cause beaucoup de
dégâts nous on ne fait jamais de
déclarations de quoi du coalition comme
ça s'appelle avant des élections parce
que nous considérons que c'est les
électeurs qui élisent à la suite des
élections les partis ont à s'accommoder
du résultat que les électeurs leur ont
fourni c'est ça la démocratie
en allemagne on exclut en italie on
exclut on ne pas pas de connexion avec
celui de celui là pas de collection avec
cela ce qui reste n'est
vraisemblablement pas viable donc pas de
coalition du tout donc on revote jusqu'à
ce que le résultat plaisent ça n'est pas
ça n'est pas une attitude qu'il a pour
le lieu n'est pas une démocratie mature
écoutez nous suivrons en attendant ce
qui va se passer d'ici quelques mois on
continue comme je vous le disais
direction l'autriche depuis quelques
années donc les autrichiens ont rétabli
le service militaire pour les seuls
garde sont une volonté qui est porté
également par la population et à l'heure
où emmanuel macron souhaitant france
instauré un service universel
obligatoires reportage de cécile 6
[Musique]
le corps va s'affaisser
les convulsions c'est quand le corps
reprend de la démonstration de force
pour ces jeunes autrichiens de 18 ans
dans cette caserne près de vienne six
cents jeunes font leur service militaire
pendant six mois
je veux
on apprend la discipline comment on doit
se comporter
on apprend les limites de notre corps on
fait du sport assez de sport et on
apprend à se servir des arbres en 2013
les autrichiens ont choisi par
référendum de garder le service national
obligatoire uniquement pour les garçons
la question d'y intégrer les filles ne
s'est même pas posée aujourd'hui ils
sont 60% à choisir la formation de
soldats les 40% restants opte pour un
service civil neuf mois dans les métiers
du social avec des personnes âgées
handicapées aux urgences médicales comme
ici à jouer knitter une association de
premiers secours ou fridolin 18 ans a
choisi de travailler
mais lorsque tout ce qui relève bien la
mandibule là je suis au maximum voilà
comme ceci jusqu'au marquage noir et
maintenant ces injections un service
militaire pour moi c'était hors de
question
le service civil m'a toujours plu à
tirer quand je ne considère pas que le
service militaire et beaucoup de sens ça
n'apporte pas grand chose pour plus tard
le service civil avoir plus d'expérience
et aussi en formation pour les soins de
premier secours avant de faire leur
choix tout ce passe deux jours par un
centre d'admission
examen visuel tests d'urines épreuve
d'effort échographie mais aussi tests
psychologiques
ici les médecins examine de près la
santé physique et mentale des jeunes
autrichiens pour les jeunes c'est
d'abord un grand test de santé l âge de
18 ans on découvre toujours des maladies
plus ou moins bénigne de façon plus
générale
cela apporte des informations sur l'état
de santé d'une classe d'âge des jeunes
hommes autrichien à l'âge de 18 ans
autre avantage le service national
permet à toute une génération de jeunes
hommes de vivre ensemble pendant
plusieurs mois
ici ils apprennent avant tout le
sentiment d'appartenance être là les uns
pour les autres
s'engager pour les autres après aussi la
discipline l'ordre et l'obéissance le
service militaire un gage de la cohésion
nationale
sébastien est fait et politologue
pour lui le triche n'en a pas besoin
mais sa matra l'islam
l'autriche est un pays neutre ne menace
personne c'est complètement irrationnel
de maintenir une armée qui de toute
façon en cas de défense serait incapable
de mettre sur pied quelque chose c'est
pourquoi la solution pour l'autriche
s'est d'abolir l'armée et d'utiliser
l'argent pour le social et de payer les
gens correctement einstein dégâts
réinvestir les 460 millions d'euros du
service national dont les salaires du
social c'est l'idée de ce politologue
car selon lui les services civils font
du personnel à bas coût payé 750 euros
par mois il tire les revenus des
travailleurs sociaux vers le bas retour
à l'association joannie terre
ou le directeur du personnel lucas a
fait le calcul sont les services civils
il serait effectivement plus difficile
de faire fonctionner son association les
professionnels apportent 47 % des heures
travaillées sont incrustés nantel et les
jeunes du service civil à peu près 30 9%
mais dans la plupart des cas
l'expérience suscite des vocations
ils apprennent un métier chez nous ils
apprennent le métier de secouriste c'est
une formation professionnelle reconnue
pour ses sonars nos craintes et après
cette formation ils peuvent travailler
professionnellement ou officiellement
dans des organismes de sauvetage saturn
en europe et réfléchir à un modèle
autrichien dont pourrait s'inspirer la
france emmanuel macron a réaffirmé sa
volonté d'instaurer un service
obligatoire de trois à six mois
ouvert aux femmes reste à voir la
faisabilité d'un tel projet
[Musique]
alors à l'instar de l'autriche à
d'autres pays européens rétabli le
service militaire on parle de service
universel obligatoire donc en france
avec mon parti civique et l'autre
militaire dominique riquet c'est lié à
quoi tout ça parce qu'on voit par
exemple que du côté de la suède des pays
du nord de l'europe ou à l'est et une
peur de la russie d'autres c'est pour
une volonté de cohésion nationale de
création de lien social
est ce qu'on demande pas trop aux
militaires dans cette histoire mais je
pense d'abord que compte tenu de
l'évolution des technologies de défense
le caractère défensif entre guillemets
du de la conscription deux nuls ouais
y'a pas d'intérêt militaire
en revanche c'est un grand intérêt
social ya l'intérêt de bilan bilan de
santé bilan de connaissances bilan
niveau culturel bilan des confédérations
la journée d'appel non je pense qu'il
faut un peu plus de temps que cinq ans
même
et la deuxième chose après il ya
probablement un apprentissage à
l'intégration dans le corps social
après les modalités des portes de
problèmes financiers combien ça coûte de
poèmes de je pense que fais tu empruntes
défier des versions se pose pas depuis
les versions même sujet sur le plan
sociétal sur la cession en autriche il
s'est même pas posé le débat s'est pas
posée c'est vrai que l'autriche la
différence
l'autriche est différente de celle du
flambeau comment le luxembourgeois que
vous êtes frank engel voit ce débat je
vais vous dire que chez nous on a aboli
le service militaire en 67 68 mon père
l'a encore fait c'est la dernière année
de naissance qui a dû le faire ils
étaient six mois à l'époque et
aujourd'hui je crois que notre armée
et même plus étendus qu'elles étaient à
l'époque parce que ça me semble
représenter un intérêt de formation
d'engagement et il ya d'autres égards et
moi je m'entends être d'accord avec ceux
qui disent il y a une utilité sociale à
un certain service pendant un certain
temps
non il doit pas être militaire et peut
être civile comme comme comme cela se
vérifie en beaucoup d'endroits et je ne
considère pas qu'il soit complètement
inutile de de ce panier un peu dans un
métier à vocation sociale pendant
pendant quelques mois même si ce n'est
pas royal m'en payer mais ce n'est plus
non ce n'est pas pour cela qu'on est con
le fait non plus donc moi je moi je n'y
serai pas opposé pour chez nous pour
l'instant la question se pose se pose
très peu mais je vais vous dire
franchement un ajout de plus en plus de
jeunes ça mène à l'école avec parents et
avocats pour contester n'importe quelle
note qui leur semblent insuffisantes
un peu de service militaire ou sociale
pourrait faire du gambien celio alors
j'écoutais dominique riquet tout à
l'heure et je me disais effectivement
que si un service militaire nouvelle
formule servait encore au 21ème siècle à
faire un bilan sur la santé sur
l'éducation
c'est quand même un prof d'échec assez
important que ça passe par sept par cet
intermédiaire là la deuxième chose que
je voulais indiquer ce que
s'il s'agit de faire un bilan s'il
s'agit de vérifier le degré d'adhésion
de de remobiliser un peu ce degré
d'adhésion sur la nation des journées
d'appel c'est bien même s'il faut
probablement que ce soit plus long et ma
fille l'afl a trouvé ça ma peur des
goûts heureusement inutile donc il ya il
ya probablement une longueur et un
contenu offert vie ce qui me frappe le
plus c'est que je relisais la
déclaration du président de la
république je sais pas si c'était quand
il était déjà président ou quand il
était candidat et il indiqué il ne
s'agit pas de réinventer le service
militaire mais de donner je cite à la
jeunesse de france des causes à défendre
des combats à mener dans les domaines
social environnemental culturel
quand dans le même temps le secteur
associatif qui travaillent sur ces
domaines environnemental social culturel
depuis des années dans les contacts avec
les publics en difficulté dans
l'éducation populaire et malmené de
cette manière la loi un moment donné
lorsque le menu le débat est vraiment
mal posée mais est-ce qu'il faut pas à
l'heure où la france ou la belgique
notamment sont touchés par le terrorisme
l'allemagne est nécessaire de remettre
aussi un peu des idées autour de la
notion de défense autour de la notion de
nation
est-ce que c'est pas aussi important si
bien sûr mais je les dis c'est possible
au travers de ces journées d'appel après
on ne l'appelle comme on veut on les
indics comme on veut mais on peut les
faire plus longues on peut donner un
programme plus dense qui sont
effectivement plus centré sur cet aspect
là pour interroger les jeunes dans leurs
regards vis-à-vis de la république
vis-à-vis de ce qui se passe dans leur
dans leur monde et les sortir aussi de
leur milieu
trop trop serré pour résines de leur
donner effectivement donne une autre
perspective et une autre verte
il y avait des cct bilange pas d'accord
avec ce que dit sylvie parce que on voit
bien moi je n'ai vu dans l'exercice de
la profession médicale combien tout
bourde passe à travers les trous même si
le système il est organisé notamment
quand même s'il ya un échec de ce
système et oui mais simplement le
système ne peut pas prétendre
quelle que soit sa qualité peuvent à
présent tout seul dans ce cas les dix
reprises sur le vrai lurel je veux dire
ce temps bilan et ce temps de service
c'est pas c'est bien sûr au service de
la collectivité mais c'est aussi au
service des jeunes c'est eux qui doivent
profiter de ce temps de sociabilisation
de socialisation et puis peut-être aussi
effectivement du goût de la discipline
du sens commun de la capacité d'être
ensemble de penser aux autres de faire
équipe
frank engel est ce que ça veut pas dire
et vous aurez le mot de la fin sur cette
question que l'éducation a globalement
échoué aussi si on en arrive à faire
appel aux militaires mais on peut on
peut qualifier tous des chaque mois je
mange moi je vais dire que l'éducation
dont beaucoup de nos pays et
probablement dans tous à d'énormes
lacunes aujourd'hui parce que ce qu'elle
pratique qu'est ce qu'elle prodigue
n'est plus en phase avec ce qu'il faut
en tout premier lieu à la société cette
école ne produit pas d'engagement civile
ni civique la très peu d'instruction
civique dans cette école n'importe où
n'importe où on regarde ce n'est
d'ailleurs pas avec un service militaire
ou civil qu'on combat le terrorisme
terrorisme doit être combattue par des
spécialistes des gens qui savent
exactement ce qu'ils font c'est pas avec
les jeunes recrues des 18 ans qu'on va
qu'on va combattre et quoi que ce soit
mais chaque chose à sa place mais
écoutez on suivra un rapport qui devrait
pas le président de la république
devrait rendre en france et ses prêts
ses préconisations d'ici la fin du mois
c'est l'heure du checkpoint préparé par
la rtbf cette semaine guillaume gilbert
s'est penché sur le règlement dublin
il semblerait qu on puisse si l'on veut
ne pas l'appliquer alors vrai ou faux
c'est le checkpoint la suite
comment les demandeurs d'asile sont ils
répartis au sein de l'union européenne
début 2018 le président de la ligue
belge des droits de l'homme alexis de
soif déclaré que la belgique pouvait
décider de ne plus suivre le règlement
de dublin selon ce règlement c'est le
premier pays de l'union européenne dans
lequel le réfugié pose un pied qui est
en charge de sa demande d'asile
ce n'est qu'une faculté on pourrait
s'engager la belgique en disant nous
appliquons plus le règlement dublin
cette question tous les états membres
peuvent se la poser peut-on décider de
ne plus respecter le règlement de dublin
le principe de base c'est celui du
premier pays membre dans lequel le
réfugié a été inscrit comme demandeur
d'asile
[Musique]
si un syrien entre en europe via
l'italie et bien faire une demande
d'asile en belgique
celle ci devra le renvoyer vers l'italie
qui devra elle prendre en charge la
procédure d'asile
résultat des pays comme la grèce ou
l'italie fli nice par crouler sous les
procédures d'asile
la commission européenne a bien présenté
une réforme du système de dublin afin de
mieux répartir les migrants entre les
états membres
mais cette réforme n'a pas encore été
approuvé par le conseil européen
la règle du premier pays d'entrée doit
donc être toujours appliqué sauf dans
certains cas si l'état membre en
question présente de mauvaises
conditions d'accueil
c'est le cas de la grèce si le réfugié
un membre de sa famille proche dans un
autre état membre
il existe aussi deux exceptions qui
permette d'office de contourner le
règlement de dublin pour des raisons
humanitaires
si le réfugié es malade par exemple ou
pour des raisons de souveraineté un état
membre peut décider de prendre en charge
une demande d'asile
mais il s'agit bien là d'exception qui
ne peuvent pas remplacer la règle
générale du premier pays accueillant
si la belgique et d'autres états membres
décident de ne plus suivre le règlement
de dublin
ce serait donc contraire au droit
européen ce que dit alexis de soi et
donc contestable si les contestaires je
vous voyais un peu trépigner en gros un
état souverain peut décider de ne plus
appliquer le règlement c'est ce qu'a en
gala merkel a fait en 2015 par exemple
oui d'une certaine manière mais d'une
façon sûre en revanche
l'italie la grèce et les pays sur le
pourtour de l'union européenne resteront
probablement sur le pourtour dans
qu'elles ont les mêmes pressions
géographique
qu'ils se rassurent elle donc le vrai
problème c'est que le règlement dublin
ne fonctionne pas et qu'il faut lui
substituer quelque chose de différent
qui fonctionnent avec des critères
objectifs ce que le parlement a fait et
de ce qui a été voté de façon très
majoritaire et nous sommes dans
l'attenté de la réponse des états
membres du conseil il manifestement ne
sont pas d'accord sur cette
responsabilité partagée et sur cette
solidarité donc on va voir si ça va il
ya une négociation justement entre la
chancelière allemande et le président
macron pour un paquet autour de cette
question migratoire avant le prochain
conseil de juin merci à vous de nous
avoir éclairé et d'avoir décrypter avec
nous cette actualité cette forte
actualité c'est fini pour cette semaine
mais vous pouvez bien entendu revoir en
replay et à l'envi cette émission sur
nos sites respectifs vous retrouverez
ahmed tazir la semaine prochaine depuis
ce parlement à bruxelles très belle
semaine à tous ciao
[Musique]